pas de féerie de trappes classique cette
année mais un autre événement la
remplacer tous aux fenêtres
jeudi vendredi et samedi des
déambulations eu lieu dans tous les
quartiers parade lumineuse et sonore
déambulation d'artistes camion musicale
la magie de noël était bien la situation
copine 0 but les rues pour dante rate on
déambule au taux d'aidé des immeubles et
les gens savent public et son génial
auxerre les samedis après midi un grand
jeu était organisé il fallait résoudre
des énigmes en se promenant dans la
ville
l'occasion de croiser au détour d'une
rue le père noël j'ai tout tout tout
aimé et moi si content que ma maman est
made laisser aller avec les éditeurs et
j'ai vu père noël et nous est donnée des
boues et adoré les activités
j'adore la vie théâtrale parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'activités les enfants ont
aussi pu observer les illuminations de
noël cette année elles ont été
entièrement installé par le service
technique municipal
une façon de faire des économies et d'en
mettre davantage dans la ville
c'était donc un cours soulagement pour
les intermittents du spectacle qui ont
pu travailler et un peu de magie pour
les enfants et des parents
dernière ligne droite avant noël
patience il ne reste maintenant plus que
trois jours à attendre